5 25 on your wednesday morning you might
have missed the nevada department of
transportation's in-person meeting on
the future of the 95-515 but lots of
opportunities for you to go ahead and
weigh in now as much as the big squeeze
is affecting drivers that is just the
tip of the traffic iceberg known as
n.dap that stands for downtown access
project which may rebuild the entire
freeway from west of the spaghetti bowl
over to charleston now all of the
powerpoint slides that they showed at
the public meeting are online including
the age of the freeway most of it was
built like 42 years ago some of it more
than 50 years ago they're talking about
going from three lanes in each direction
to four or five if you count hov lanes
they're talking about choosing options
that range from putting the freeway on
the ground instead of overhead or
keeping it above ground and then
widening or maybe doing nothing they're
also showing how the daily traffic of
175
000 cars a day three years ago is
projected to jump by another fifty
thousand cars a day by twenty forty now
the online public meeting will be up
until the fifteenth of next month we've
got the links to the project and the
virtual public meeting on
eightnewsnow.com clip traffic than
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down the phone
something's driving you crazy email me
traffic eight at eight news now dot com